So now having seen the sequential memory consistency model, what we can do is go
back to our original example, and ask the
question, what are all the possible outcomes for
this particular set of memory accesses performed on
p1 and p2? Now what possible values can
d and c get? Well obviously, you can get the first choice, no problem with that.
Can get the second choice, it can get
the third choice, and as we illustrated earlier,
all of these are just interleaving of these
memory accesses on P1 and P2. But the fourth
one Is not possible with sequential consistency, because
there's no interleaving of these memory axes and these
memory axes that'll result in this particular outcome.
That's comforting, that's exactly what we thought would be
a useful thing to have in a
memory-consistency model that gives only intuitive results and,
and makes sure that non-intuitive results don't happen.
Memory consistency model is what the application programmer
needs to be aware of, to develop his
code and know that it will execute correctly
on the shared memory machine. As operating system
designers, however, we need to help make sure
that this code runs quickly. To do that,
we need to understand how to implement the model
efficiently. And also the relationship between hardware and software
that makes it possible to achieve this goal. So
now, we understand the memory consistency model. What
is the model that is presented to the programmer?
That's what memory consistency model is. On the other
hand, cache coherence is how is the system implementing
the model in the presence of private
caches? So this is a handshake, a partnership
between hardware and software, between the application
programmer and the system, in order to make
sure that the consistency model is actually
implemented correctly by the cache coherence mechanism that
is ingrained in the system. And the system
implementation of cache coherence. Is itself a hardware-software
trade off. Now for instance one possibility, is
that the hardware is only giving shared address
space. It's not giving you any way of
making sure that the caches are coherent, but it
is giving you the shared address space. And
it is letting the software, the system software
ensure that this contract is somewhat satisfied. And
the working of the cache coherence maintained in software
by the system. That's one possibility, and that is what is called a non-cache
coherent shared address multiprocessor. Meaning that There
is shared address space, that's available for all
the processors, there is private caches for holding data that you bring from
memory, but, if you modify data, it is a problem of the system software to make
sure that the caches remain coherent. So it's non-cache coherent. That is called
NCC shared memory multi-processor. The other possibility
of course is that, the hardware does
everything. It provides the shared address space,
but it also maintains cache coherence in
hardware. And that's what is called a
cache coherent multi-processor, or a CC multi-processor.